When you make a cartoon about a prehistoric
family, you usually end up taking a few liberties
with reality.
From caveman strength to Paleolithic physics,
here are some things that only adults notice
in The Croods.
The environment the Croods reside in is stark
and barren.
It's a dusty wasteland occupied by feisty
birds and a cat-owl hybrid with a caveman
vendetta.
Don't sweat it though, kiddos, our ancestors
are mighty and resilient.
They can throw massive stones and run like
the wind.
It's a cartoon grab bag of Wile E. Coyote
shenanigans.
However, in the first few minutes — after
an outstretched hall-of-fame catch sends him
sliding headfirst into a boulder — the family's
patriarch, Grug, throws out a light-hearted
quip that will have parents raising an eyebrow
or two.
After fighting tooth and nail for their breakfast,
which is just one big egg, Grug ends up only
getting a smidgeon of a portion by the time
the family has had their fill.
His response?
"Oh, that's all right.
I ate last week."
Contextually, the joke works and sets a fun
tone.
But given all their physical advantages, it's
surprising that the Croods are able to maintain
their hulkish physiques eating only one egg
per week.
They need to eat in order to survive, and
that's made clear throughout the journey.
Maybe it's the caveman DNA, because once we
meet Guy, he's a bit leaner and not nearly
as strong as any of the Croods.
That's an interesting fact given that he has
an easier time getting food and even introduces
them to the concept of "leftovers."
The leader of the pack is the steadfast father
figure, Grug, and he's done what every parent
hopes to achieve — he's kept his children
alive by instilling in them a perpetual fear
of everything.
Granted, it comes from a nurturing place.
Considering we believe them to be the last
caveman family — and every other family
around them has succumbed to the horrors of
their world — it's reasonable that he chooses
to lead this way.
But is this almighty head of the family content
in his role as beefcake supreme?
Of course not.
Any deviation from his plans causes him to
become frantic.
He's so overbearing that his wife Ugga has
to physically put her hands on him and push
him away at one point.
Good thing there's some modicum of modern
family roles in this Stone Age family, otherwise
this adventure could've gotten dark.
With their circumstances, there are unfortunate
attributes that need to be overlooked for
the sake of survival.
Grug's incessant neediness is one of them.
He needs his hand held through most of the
film.
When it comes time to sink or swim, we watch
Grug sink to the bottom of a lake with all
the melancholy a primitive mind can muster.
Kids will think Grug is being a goofball.
Adults will empathize with his plight.
And everyone will feel like he's smothering
them.
The human vocal range, unfortunately, has
its limits.
We can only shout for so long, and our voices
can only reach so far.
Good thing our ancestors wrapped their lips
around the husks of abandoned snail houses
and discovered the booming might of the conch.
It would appear the ancient founder of the
first megaphone was none other than Guy.
The conch shell is formed by aquatic snails
and is mostly found near large water sources.
To find one anywhere but the ocean is extremely
rare and usually means that an ancient waterway
once existed there.
And at the end of The Croods, our heroes all
reach the ocean and venture onward into the
next chapter of their story.
The fact that this is their final destination
in the film implies everyone had yet to reach
the ocean before.
So how is it they possess so many of these
conch shells?
Guy is handing them out like candy.
Even the most inquisitive kid may be surprised
at the surplus of conch shells that Guy has
in his satchel when they're setting off into
a labyrinth of tunnels.
Guy may be an idea man, but he still seems
naive enough to believe he can actually catch
the sun.
Chances are he hadn't spent a lot of his time
alone out in a different ocean, farming for
conch shells.
In the apparent final moments of Grug's time
with his family, he sums up everything that
he and his daughter Eep need to talk about
beautifully.
It's the most succinct the moment could possibly
be, with the caveman pulling his daughter
in for a hug.
She then inquires as to the name of this new
comforting invention.
He declares that it will be called a hug
"Because it rhymes with Grug."
It's a misty-eyed moment that ends in a father
telling his daughter he loves her.
The kids have probably checked out on the
mushy stuff at this point, but adults are
probably asking how the heck there's a word
for something as complex as "love" but not
something as straightforward as a "hug."
Cavemen are extremely literal, as displayed
by Eep's innocent assumption that fire is
alive because Guy said it was "dying."
The words they use are attached to actions
and things — caves, rocks, run, smash, etc.
It's cute to have "hug" be introduced into
their lexicon — thus displaying Grug's contribution
and evolution — but anyone who's had their
heart put through the ringer knows "love"
is a drastically more complex word to process.
It feels like a missed opportunity to build
on the formula and bring in the Neanderthals'
interpretation of the emotion.
Maybe the film's creators felt like that would
be too much mushy stuff.
Anyone trying not to cry in front of their
kids when the Croods all pay tribute to their
fallen patriarch will agree.
It's unlikely that children are keying in
on metaphors when they're indulging in a visual
blitz of colors and silliness, but adults
may have a hard time not seeing cultural similarities
between our world and the caveman world running
through The Croods.
It's all the more obvious with Nicolas Cage
stepping in as the dad who won't change with
the times.
His dry, annoyed drawl helps the movie drive
its point home — adapt or slip into a crack
in the ground and melt into a river of magma.
There's another character whose visual attributes
also help make things apparent, and that's
Guy, of course.
The scrawny idea factory's representation
of progress is visualized, with a healthy
dose of snark, by his man bun.
The hairstyle is a telltale sign of the liberal
hipster, especially considering when the movie
was released, in 2013.
Guy innocently posits a better approach to
situations they have long dealt with, but
he lacks the leadership that comes from years
of fighting off predators with your fists.
And it's not that Grug or Guy are wrong about
their approaches — they're just different.
If any parents are upset with the representation
of either side, then they're looking at the
entire film all wrong.
After all, our heroes reach their new paradise
by working together.
Each of them grows in their own way and learns
an unfortunate lesson in the process — mother-in-laws
are immortal, and you best just get used to
them.
Anyone who's taken part in a Boy Scout camping
trip and felt a primal rage bubble up from
within while they spin sticks between kindling
might have some major issues with the way
The Croods deals with fire.
Trying to master the strike of flint is an
incredibly annoying endeavor, but evidently,
Guy doesn't have an issue sparking up some
flames in a heartbeat in the middle of stressful
situations.
Heck, he can create a fire strong enough to
withstand the wind gusts of thousands of carnivorous
birds.
"It comes from where you come from?"
"No, I make it."
"Make some for me!"
Child audiences are no doubt unaware of the
woes of campfire construction, as camping
often means electrical outlets and parking
spaces nowadays.
Those of us who endured the "joy" of camping
in the middle of nowhere know how difficult
the fire-building process can be.
We'll let it slide, though.
After all, it's more enjoyable to see how
things pan out for the Croods instead of them
getting mauled by the wave of flesh-eating
birds.
It also makes the family's introduction to
Guy and the concept of fire a majestic experience.
The zany Looney Tunes tomfoolery of The Croods
injects the proper amount of innocence into
what might otherwise be a boring tale about
how even Nicolas Cage can change.
However, the film begins to stretch it a bit
far at points.
It's a child's animated film, and we're trying
not to nitpick, but right around the time
Grug grabs the family and leaps off a cliff,
most adults are spitting out their chardonnay,
completely flabbergasted that they all could
survive a fall from the equivalent of a skyscraper
rooftop.
Well, it's a good thing that cavemen are immune
to falls, apparently.
Especially Gran, who can take quite a beating
for an elderly woman in need of a walking
cane.
The first time we see the family hunt, the
roles are decided by Gran being substituted
for a quarter, and she's tossed into the air
in a game of heads or tails.
In any animated adventure, a few falls are
expected, and they induce the necessary giggles.
But The Croods stretches it to the point of
incredulity.
They fall a lot.
The family members are launched into the sky
by a whale geyser and land on their faces
in a field.
They fall into giant mazes after the ground
decides to suddenly explode.
They even get slingshotted into the air by
trap mishaps.
But every time they fall, they just get right
back up, which is actually kind of a sweet
message for kids.
In the real world, it takes much longer than
we'd like to teach a cute little puppy that
the rug is not an appropriate place to drop
off a fresh loaf.
In other words, adults are all too aware of
nature's primal indifference.
Kids are spoiled by generations of species'
taming and most likely haven't been kicked
by a mule while trying to get fresh milk for
their Fruity Pebbles.
So, when the Croods amass a healthy collection
of pet friends by the end of their journey,
the little ones don't even bat an eyelash.
According to our favorite cave-dwelling family
unit, animals are shockingly easy to tame
in the Paleolithic era.
The Croods even gain a mount in the form of
a different version of the hellish owl-cat
that was hunting them at the beginning of
the film.
But there's no explanation as to how they
tame that beast.
The implication is that animals come with
a built in "pet" setting.
The only thing you need to do in order to
flip that switch is to not run away screaming.
When the walls of the Croods' little ravine
suddenly come smashing together, they lose
their cave — the only safe hideaway they've
ever known.
To the amazement of the family, though, just
behind their cave walls is a vibrant jungle.
All it took was tectonic calamity to expose
them to a world that looks suspiciously like
James Cameron's Avatar.
Obviously, they aren't actually on the mystical
moon of Pandora, but the environment is lush
and colorful enough to make you think that
a rich vein of unobtanium runs beneath the
surface.
Not to say animators took a page from the
Cameron Bible, but the vivid colors all breathe
a certain familiarity into the jungle.
Kids respond to bright, colorful images, so
we can't claim the market has been cornered
on the color spectrum.
But the creatures we come across don't help
differentiate from the two worlds, like the
flock of dual-winged birds flying over the
beach in the final sequences.
Giant rideable tigers and vibrant, sentient
flowers also help The Croods' world feel reminiscent
of Pandora.
Most likely, it's just us jaded adults being
unable to enjoy new things and connecting
with Grug too much.
After all, no one's got a monopoly on pretty
colors.
Still, if you squint, it's a little hard to
tell the difference between the two films.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.